quelque chose que les français savent
mal aussi c'est que bon il ya eu des
soucis sécuritaires au sel boko haram
bon les mines du niger ont tendance à
affirmer au profit d'un
approvisionnement qui vient de plus en
plus des pays comme le kazakhstan le
kazakhstan un mort sur le temps aux
herbes et fcc 1 en termes de dictature
c'est très très haut dans le game 1 si
je peux utiliser cette expression est
évidemment c'est des choses dont on
n'entend pas parler en france on parce
qu'on passe condyle de l'uranium avec
eux il faut pas oublier cette question
de temps faites d'appréhension des
droits de l'homme à géométrie variable
entre l'arabie saoudite qu'on fait pas
chier parce que on leur vend des armes
le kazakh sans qu'on fait pas chier du
tout parce que on leur achète de
l'uranium et des pays comme comme la
russie le venezuela que pour le coup
vous fait chier parce que parce que
c'est pas dans notre alignement
géostratégie
[Musique]